كانوا يخلونا زي عزك الكلاب نعو اه ان ما
عوتش يضربوك ان ما نوتش يضربوك ان ما بعتش
يضربوك يكسروك فش لازم تعمل اللي بدهم
اياه ممنوع تطلب حاجه لو قلت بدي اشرب
طبعا الضرب بينزل على راسك او على اي جزء
من جسمك فيش لا فرق ما بين صغير وكبير
يعني انا عمري 62 سنه لان ضربوني هوايه في
صدري انا عندي مشاكل في الجهاز
التنفسي وشلح ونا على الينين زي ما جابتك
امك شلحوني وغمي ونا واخدوه عد على النقب
وعدوا يطبوا فينا بوكسات فما وصلنا في
الباصات خشينا عدوا يكهرب فينا وشربو حبوب
هدوسه حبوب هدوسه وميه وشبه ومش عارف ايش
وميه [__] وعكره ويخبط
عروسنا ترفع راسك يخبطك في الدبشك يخبطك
في اي ايش في ايده بعدين كان معاهم ح زي
البشما في الايد يخطن
فيها وانا قاعد الصبح حرجني في السيجاره
في ظهري وقاعد يغلط علي ويسب علي هيقت
ظهري اغر هيك بعديها وساعه ما حملونا
العصر عدوا يضربوا فينا كمان اخويا عنده
مصارينه مقطعه عامل عمليه في مصارينه خذت
بالك مرس مع الكهرباء يصير يصوت يقول لهم
يا عمي انا مريض كل ما يقولوا له انا يقول
لهم انا مريض يزيد اللي الميه ميه يقعد
يحط راسنا في الميه يمشي على الجزاز يقعد
يقوللنا هذا حماس هذا فتح هذا يعني اللي
هان صواريخ وهان صواريخ زي هيك اقعد
يقولنا يقول له ما نعرفش يا عمي احنا
اميين احنا بونا على حالنا احنا انا كمان
احنا يا عمي من كتر الضرب واللي تيجي تقول
له بدك تخش الحمام يقول لك لا ممنوع تخش
حمام
ممنوع اه معصبات عينيا وايدي 30
يوم اه 30 يوم
ا هو كيف لما بيجي يسوقك وانت مش شايف
بتعت في حاجه كان رماك على الارض لا اول
18 يوم ما اكلتش ولا حاجه غير الميه بعدين
يا تفاحه يا خياره يوم تفاحه يوم خياره
انا نسبه الي حطيني في خيمه وحط الباروده
هنا على كتب قاللي اختار لك موته او نحطك
في البحر او قلت له ده ربنا كتب لي
الشهاده امو شهيد قال لي اختار يمين ولا
شمال ق بعرفش قال لي يلا بديش خليتك متشد
تعال على اليمين من 10 ل 12 ساعه على
الحصمه ولبسوني شو اسمه هذا بنبظ عشان
ممنوع اروح على الحمام تعمال اعمالها
لحالي قعدوا لي ثلاث ايام على الركب ممنوع
تتحرك تتحرش ترتاح لما تيجي ساعهه الغداء
وع ساعات وانا معلق مره يرفع ايديه هيك من
ورا ومرات من قدام ويمسك الجنزير يرفع
يرفع ويتركه من يوم الحبس وبصب فيجري هذ
خبطني والله في البسطار مزعلي اياها من
اول
يوم شيه لقيت 18 يوم ماسر ججونا قبل ما
يسرنا بثلاث ايام كانوا يخوا على
الدور ي خزق الدور كلها اليوم الرابع ما
لقينا الا الكباشات
والدبابات جايين وبيجوا في المكان كله
حجزو في شقه كانوا هم قاعدين فيها
مستوطنين فيها في المنطقه يعني قعدنا
بالضبط 48 ساعه لا ميه ولا اكل ولا شي
وغير الكلبشات بس ورا في الظهر طبعا وضرب
وزله اهان يجي يلاقيك نايم يحمل قداحه
ويكو في ظهرك يعني طفى السيجاره في ظهري
كذا مره حد من الشباب يقوله بدنا نشرب
بميه يقول له افتح تمك عشان اشربه لما
يفتح الشاب تمه الشاب مغم عيه مش شاي ما
يفتح تمه اللي هو يتفه في تم يعني انا
ردلي وصلت
هالقد يوقفني على الشبك يشبهنا في وشب كان
معنا مقطوع على ايده من بدايه الحرب يشبح
على ايد واحده خيه واقف بالثلاث ساعات
واربعه كل ساعه بحسها باسبوع تعذيب ما
يعلم فيه الا الله يعني لما جينا اليوم
نروح عذبونا عن ال 18 يوم اللي سبق نوجه
بس للعالم ينظر للاسرع دول هدول اولاد
عالم وناس مش بهايم هدول اولاد عالم
وناس